your mind here's the debate you're upset
but we discussed it okay sounds good
well i think we are live yes no maybe
we're live episode number one
uh 58 we haven't done a podcast for a
minute we were in las vegas and la the
last couple days
we had a chance to see the gas prices in
l.a yeah a lot about that today it seems
like a lot of stuff has happened
that uh we want to talk about
specifically the shooting the tragic
event that took place in
uvalde san antonio which i've been to i
went to an event over there drive tanks
there's a very uh uh interesting place
we'll talk about that of course um and
then hillary clinton you know some
comments by ray dalio about the markets
business
um
guns uh gun law obviously a lot of
people are chiming in on what's going on
with the
uh issue that seems to be the topic of
discussion we got a couple things that i
saw with henry uh kissinger in regards
to ukraine and russia that kind of threw
some people off and then we have uh the
lovely catalina lauf here with us the
former advisor at the u.s department of
commerce she's known as as anti aoc she
ran
uh in 11th congressional district in
illinois it's great to have you on the
podcast thank you so much for having me
and your shirt if you can tell everybody
yes freedom over fear that's our
campaign slogan i love it freedom over
fear and then we have our tom ellsworth
here tom does not have a fancy shirt
he's just wearing his regular is that a
brook shirt or what kind of whatever
kind of a shirt it is of course that
shirt that's great it's awesome
we'll take it okay so that was the
compliment i assume a dad shirt for tom
yeah absolutely he's got a dad's shirt
he's got dad jokes he's clearly got a
dad bod he's got a dad haircut he's
doing his thing he crossed the line
right there you crossed him
he's a high-end dad
you you just offended a few people by
the way by saying that okay kim is
probably going to send a message to you
and you're going to get blocked on
instagram
kim's great all right so uh folks before
we get into it we i want to go straight
into topics but before we get straight
into topics
uh i i do want to have catalina if you
don't mind take a quick moment and share
with the audience your background how
you got this reputation this name of
anti-aoc you're running because you're
young you're coming up you're vocal
you're smart you have strong opinions
tell the audience about your background
yes so running in illinois 11th district
it is in the northern illinois suburbs
it's a very i grew up in a small town
and what we illinoisans get so
frustrated with is that we get drowned
out by cook county and the chicago
democrats where in reality a lot of
illinois is actually pretty republican
and so i'm running for congress look
i've seen over the years that our
districts are being flipped every single
cycle and they're recruiting the the
left is recruiting these far left young
female voices like aoc in the squad
they're being heavily funded a lot of
them are just puppets and they're
flipping hard republican seats and
that's what happened in in my home
district a few years ago
my mom came here legally from guatemala
central america she grew up in poverty
my grandmother picked coffee beans
my dad is a small business owner and you
know i was born and raised with this
unapologetic love for the country to
support small business to
you know support our flag support our
military back the blue these very
american principles free market
economics that i now see completely
under attack the american dream that
made my life possible that made my
family's life possible when they came
here
is under attack and we need strong
voices we need fighters we need everyday
americans everyday people to step up now
and push back the far left because
they're winning the war right now both
culturally and economically but by the
way were you always did you always have
these beliefs or did you ever
uh uh question them and you said well i
don't know you know these guys all they
care about is money these guys you know
they're too much about this they're too
much about that or was it always a thing
were you always a conservative i was
always a conservative and is that
because mom dad the upbringing or both
you know i think part of it is the
upbringing working the small business my
dad taught me uh business at a young age
but also i was able to
go to these countries i was able to go
to central america and see what
oppression and poverty looks like and
what happens when there aren't economic
opportunities that was drilled into my
head from a young age and to look at a
country where we have all the
possibilities endless possibilities here
in america and and to preserve that is
so important i also grew up with stories
of world war ii veterans and uh you know
people who who there's a real cost of
freedom in history that our country
stands for that is being lost in this
generation and so
that upbringing uh also just seeing what
things have been changing over from a
cultural perspective have actually made
me more conservative and more strong in
my values and my ideology so your
parents both are conservative yes okay
yeah and who were you in high school if
we were in high school together 10th
grade 11th grade who were you oh my god
uh were you the athlete were you the
grades were you the 4.5 gpa were you oh
my god no i basically i got kicked out
of school i was the the
the rebel
yeah really in high school yes i was
homeschooled actually because i was just
so sick of
edu the education system and i was
self-taught and went to college at 15.
and
was it miami you went to miami
international ohio or something like
that so i graduated
high school i did a dual start program
where i was able to test into the to the
community college did my first two year
gen eds there and then was able to
transfer at a really young age to miami
of ohio and then was able to only do two
and a half years there got my degree
right away and then left got it okay
cool and then uh uh uh last but not
least so aoc you know she
you know whatever we say about aoc
politically which you know we may or may
not agree with socialism you know how
she capitalizes of all the opportunities
she's been able to get her message out
there to hundreds of millions of people
at this point the entire country knows
who she is she's got god knows how many
followers on twitter 10 15 million
followers on twitter what do you think
she's doing that's resonating because
may 11 you just had a birthday happy
birthday to you two weeks ago you had a
birthday fifth but yeah secret of my own
okay so may you put may 11th here so it
says may 5th so maybe she's at six
o'clock
birthday happy birthday
so fireworks 29 years old you your age
starts with the number two
we skip here tyler you're how old just
so we know 34 27 no 27 years old okay
and then there's there's a spike there's
no three here then it's four and five in
the room so for the 20 year olds
yourself what what makes you think and
aoc
uh is getting the kind of connection
with the younger audience where they're
saying she makes a lot of sense why is
she having so much momentum that's a
great question number one she's being
helped out by these social media
companies i would love to see how actu
how many of her actual followers are
real let's just put that out there
because they are being heavily promoted
more than conservative voices which is
why we need counter voices to them
but i think look she was she's relatable
she does these you know little videos
she was one of the first millennials
that had a strong voice in congress
everybody knew about her she was put on
this pedestal and she was heavily
marketed by the powers that be in her
party people believed in her and even if
she disrupted her establishment
candidate she was still heavily backed
and funded by people who propped her up
and so she's able to penetrate in all
these different areas whether it's
twitch or social media and in all that
to try to be relatable now everything
that she says 90 of it does not make
sense but we live especially millennials
live in this kind of soundbite culture
where they take this emotion-based
little 15-second things that she says
and then they go and run with it as we
see with these culture wars and then
that's why she's so effective but she's
actually destroying her party at the the
advantage to conservatives because
people are now coming more on our side
because she's controlling the democrats
today she controls the narrative because
she's able to raise money on her own
because of her big platform and she has
the voice to do it do you think she's
dumb
yes you think she's that i do really i
think she's dumb um no okay i'll say
this she's smart because she's smart at
manipulating i think does anybody like
that
is deceptive okay in terms of raw
intelligence um i would say some of her
things that she says about the economy
and things just don't make sense so from
that perspective no so economically and
her degree is in what isn't her degree
in economics yeah isn't it isn't an
economic so yeah some of the stuff she
talks about
it just makes you wonder like who who
the teachers are today i'd love to go to
college i'd love to go to one of these
uc berkeley economic classes just to sit
there as a student just to sit there and
be like go semester through like a
project you know what i'm saying like
you recorded and you wonder what these
professors are telling these kids that
are going to college about economy what
are they saying about the rich man about
the capitalists about the business owner
uh what kind of commentary because
they're shaping the mindset of these
kids did you did you watch bill maher's
uh
message he gave i think you sent it did
you send it to me yes sir you sent it to
me and the premise behind it was what he
was asking he said he said you know
we're looking at statistics about the
lgbtq community
tom have you seen this or no
recently no have you have you seen that
catalina
everybody's got to watch it go ahead no
essentially the premise is
america's getting gayer and gayer so he
shows statistic about about seven months
ago we had gad sodon right
who i think he's coming back on the
podcast yeah so we had him on and in the
middle of the podcast i asked him a
question i said do you think the media
is increasing the media and tv shows do
they have any influence over increasing
uh the lgbtq community in america says i
don't think it has any influence so
while we're talking i'm googling to see
the increasing population of
you know gays and lesbians and you see
how 30 years ago it's one percent and
it's increased to five percent
but then bill maher went full blown on
this video i i wish we could play it
where he says it started off with this
many percent then it went to five
percent then it went to this and it says
gen z
uh uh 50 of gen z or some big number
right twenty percent twenty percent
basically yeah sees themselves as part
of the lgbtq community and it says at
this pace folks in the next 10 20 years
we're all going to be gay right that's
pretty much what bill maher was talking
about but here's the point here's a
point
that right there the statistic with what
bill maher talked about gets me to think
about
something i was in the military we had
people who were gays and lesbians in the
military okay
in high school you know we had folks who
were part of a lgbt you know lg
community and we had some guys like that
guy's problem you know you kind of knew
about it right
but for it to increase the way it is
that doesn't mean a lot of these people
that are becoming lesbians and gays were
born lesbian i wonder how much of it is
grooming i wonder how much of it is
recruiting i wonder how much of it is
converting i wonder how much of it is i
don't have a dad in my picture i don't
have a strong father figure i don't have
a strong leader in my house you know
maybe you know like the famous question
which is what
how do you know you're not gay you're
not going to know unless if you kiss
somebody how do you know you're not a
lesbian you're not gonna know something
it's like maybe i am maybe oh my god i'm
not getting more attention not every
girls are not interested in me or guys
are not interested in me but she's
interested in me and this is kind of
cool so the reason why i brought this up
right off the bat is to say
you don't see statistics showing
the increased percentage of men has
increased you know by 40 in the last 20
years we don't see stats like that
you don't see the increase in women has
increased the last 20 30 40 years why
because
it's naturally we don't think about that
then how if it's scientific how is the
lgbtq community keep increasing
and we're trusting kids to go to public
schools
to be doctor indoctrinated in this
mindset
and then you're having people like aoc
whose concept is being bought by
students
because maybe teachers are grooming and
shaping their mindset this this is this
is a little bit of recruitment going on
what do you think about this you're the
one that's closer to it so happy that
you brought this up because this has
been coming up a lot on the campaign
trail
two points here i think number one when
you talk about teachers a long time ago
my mom was a teacher for 30 years right
those teachers even if they were liberal
they didn't push their ideologies to
their kids maybe from an economic you
know bad man rich things like that in
the college
ages but particularly for the younger
generations they still wanted the
star-spangled banner a lot of their dads
had fought in world war ii they were
still americans
somebody figured out along the way that
the culture war instead of economics is
the culture war is the way to change the
hearts and minds and to make kids
liberal i talk to parents every single
day on the campaign trail i talk to kids
every day on the campaign trail i just
spoke with a 13 year old last week who
said that she was confused
for an entire year of what her gender
was because in school her teachers the
millennials that were
these useful idiots i'll call them that
that don't even understand what they're
talking about half the time to the kids
these millennial teachers are pushing
the the pride flags in schools they have
groups that you're allowed to join these
lgbtq whatever groups and
and you're not allowed to join any other
groups you should probably encourage
people to join these groups that and
then it's just so it's surrounded
it's they're constantly surrounded by it
and then they get confused and then it's
a cool thing for their friends to do and
it becomes a fad she was confused for a
year because it was in her environment
yeah that's so so is there straight
groups
is there straight yes that you join like
can i go join a straight group no that's
considered hateful
so so so
you know like you know how because what
i see is here's what i here's what i if
you're gay great fine no problem we
totally have no issues with that at all
if you follow the podcast you know my
history what i you know i i'm very
comfortable with that but i don't see
people on twitter in their profile
saying part of the straight community
you know you don't see improv you you
know someone i'm saying like it's like
the reason that there's bet right
because black people needed a voice
whenever that started in the 70s now if
you had
wet white entertainment television now
we got a problem it's just and i agree
with that i don't think there should be
a but entertainers have dominated uh
media forever but i think that is more
part of the
division that's happening that that that
feeds into it now don't get me wrong i
think there's there's i'm all about
anybody that's very proud to be
mexican proud to be guatemalan proud
like ricky's michoacan
i love people that are proud of their
heritage proud to be
you know middle eastern jewish whatever
you are i have a lot of respect for that
i like i think heritage and
traditions powerful but from the
standpoint of because i am this i'm more
important than you i'm more i need to be
heard more than you
and you know trying to convert the way
it's being done today i'm not with it
that data itself can should concern
every single parent
in america that data that bill maher
showed if you've not seen it that data
that bill miles shore show everybody
who's a parent ought to be concerned
about that data today let me give you
two quick points um what happens is
people who are marginalized let's what
let's say it's the black community or
the gay community the jewish community
they start off saying hey we need a
voice like we're getting drowned out
here we're being marginalized or being
discriminated against like my dad who
grew up in detroit would tell me
when he grew up in detroit they'd used
to say signs no blacks no jews no dogs
okay straight up that's what he grew up
with in the 50s all right so you develop
a voice but then what happens is
once your voice comes becomes a little
bit louder let's say it's the lgbtq
community let's say it's the bet
community now you become part of the
mainstream and now the mainstream says
all right well
i don't i'm not lgbt what just happened
here but because you start off as a
small voice
and you become part of the mainstream
pop culture now you're you're in the
ecosystem of pop culture
the second part because if someone's
probably watching it's like what does
catalina and aoc
and political divisions have to do with
lgbt
and the
common thread there is whether it's
nature versus nurture and to the bill
mars point is that what essentially is
happening is now the debate is over this
is no longer part of nature it's now
being part of nurture
whereas one percent of people baby
boomers were gay and then two percent of
or four percent of gen x um and then
millennials now it's five percent gen z
is now it's ten percent twenty percent
it's like hold on clearly an
indoctrination is is happening and
that's essentially the common thread
there my issue is that it's being pushed
by these millennial young teachers at
such a young age and parents don't even
have a voice sometimes but also the fact
that it's influencing legislation if you
have
0.01 of the population or the statistic
on on transgenders for example and then
now people are forced to have one
bathroom or a transgender bathroom it is
influencing legislation on such a mass
scale because it's being pushed by the
far left so much that that does impact
the rest of the country why are these
small voices dominating policy you can't
even get policies passed for for
veteran health care that quickly but you
can get transgender bathrooms pushed on
a federal level in some cases that's
ridiculous to me so how do we solve it
so what's the solution so if you're if
you're saying what you're saying what is
the solution parents need to have a
voice at the school level they need to
stop this at that level and say teachers
your job is to teach my child math
social studies gym whatever and to take
your political culture war
opinions out of the classroom and then
parents need to have
need to educate their kids on what's
going on in a thoughtful way
so that they're not being it's part of
the culture now
so okay so parents uh run for school
board run for school board but okay so
say you do that what else is the
solution though tom what is there really
so i guess there's a question i'm trying
to ask is there really a solution or is
it in too deep
have they already
gotten so deep into universities and
school systems that to be able to shift
this is going to take a decade or two
and if you do how do you do it
well this is exactly the problem you
know you have um
the far left that is influencing the
kids because they want to
tell the kids
what to think they do not want the
children to be guided culturally by the
parents
they feel that they should guide the
children culturally and they feel that
um people call it grooming people call
it whatever you want
that's the issue and she's right but
this is good this is a decade-long fight
because it took a while to get here
and people are waking up to it what
happens is
mark twain said the fog comes in on
little cat feet you don't really hear it
but the fog comes in
and what has happened here over the last
20 years there has been a steady march
toward the schools bringing in content
that has increasingly left culture at
the public school level
that's where they're driving it
in dallas two of the biggest private
schools that you would say they are
probably
a tick conservative they're not
religious schools but both of them have
what's called the safe room where you
can go in and have a discussion about
being gay experimenting
gender confusion which they don't call
it confusion
and they will not tell your parents
will not tell your parents so your child
like this young woman this 13 year old
you were talking about
confused for a year could be sitting
there constantly having these
conversations in a safe room and they
don't tell the parents
but what's wrong with that especially if
you're in high school like let me just
make my point then i'll just flip back
to you kindergarten elementary school
even middle school stay the f away from
the freaking kids you're 16 years old
you're able to drive you have a car you
have a driver's license you're confused
about what you got going on you're
already making out with guys girls
you're already maybe even having sex i
got no problem in high school no problem
that's me totally adam's different in a
way no children
okay
so what you have no problem with what in
high school
with 16 18 year old kids having
conversations with guidance counselors i
don't care go in your little safe room i
don't care about that
if you if you think what how old are you
if you're girls
10 and 16. okay so let's move the 10
year old aside to the category of don't
f with her but 16 year old
17 year old 18 year old if you think her
and her friends aren't already having
these discussions you're naive
so i'm just letting you know in high
school that's what's already happening
what do you think about that tom uh
i have a fantastic relationship with my
16 year old daughter and we process
things all the time because that's
exactly what she wants to talk to her
dad about she actually by the way on
this scenario your best friend i will
tell you in this case
it is true i believe you i know i
thought seeing this i'm not even talking
about biz doc here i'm talking your
point is what you're doing to 18 year
olds in general these are conversations
that they're already having and tom
you're saying what you're saying to the
teacher you're saying to not have the
conversation for for teachers to not
have the conversation with students
no
absolutely not i don't want a teacher
bringing their views
on my child
period
now if they go in there and say hey i'm
really bothered about something these
kids are cheating i don't want to be
part of it
i don't they're in my friend group and i
don't want to get pulled into that those
conversations happen all the time in
school
all the time i don't want to get in the
middle of this but i don't want to be a
rat i don't want to be a snitch
things like this happen all the time but
the deeper things i mean you know what
happened i told you and sure going
no no i get it
because i don't want that girl to
accidentally be exposed um and bailey
came and talked to me about really bad
decision that a friend made
really bad decision her parents are very
concerned about it there's a lot of
things that go along with it but we
processed it like what was she thinking
where was she now here's the thing tom
to be fair
you can afford to put your kids through
a good private school go to public okay
go to
95 of america whatever the percentage is
that's got their kids in private public
school because of a zip code they're
only making 55 000 of your median income
say household is a hundred thousand
dollars right and they're facing those
parents are facing a war that's what
they're facing now and that's what i'm
talking about by the way if tom who's
very well off can send both of his kids
to private and by the way tom kids are
fantastic shout out to kim however
that's not the representative of what's
going on in america i taught i taught in
school i taught second grade i talked
eighth grade in miami i know what 9th
10th 11th 12th like they're already
doing stuff so if you want to live in a
fantasy world that like of course my
young daughter is going to come and talk
to me about and process issues that's
great in fantasyland and private school
that's not the reality for most of
america but i still think even in a
public school a guidance counselor if
you're under the age of 18 and you're
having these serious conversations with
somebody and opening up the parents
should be involved and that is i think
what we're talking about here is that
there's a fine line with what the role
is of the teacher to an underaged person
if you want to make the decisions after
you're 18 if you love whoever you want
to love that's fine i don't think we're
taught
from my understanding we're not talking
about that we're talking about the
younger kids who are in school and this
is being pushed on by the culture and by
their teacher totally agreed k through
eight don't even mess with the kids but
at a certain point like so talk about
seniors in high school are you saying if
if so if a sophomore
uh is confused and goes to the guidance
counselor saying hey
uh mrs johnson i'm i'm really wondering
with all these pronouns i'm really
wondering what i am i'm really
struggling with that what do you think
i'm having a hard time talking to my mom
and dad about it because i know if i
talk to my mom and dad about it they're
going to get really upset what do you
think is the right choice for me to make
well number one i any question they have
whether if you could be a straight guy
and just be like look man like i'm i'm
dealing with some bodily stuff that's
happening right now i don't feel
comfortable talking to my mom about my
boner that's just kind of weird and i'm
gonna go talk to my guidance counselor
i'm okay with that should talk to your
guidance counseling about your boner
that's i'm just saying like this is the
reality
if we want to just like sugarcoat
everything and we learn a little bit too
much about adam today i'm just saying
this is what 16 year old mr jones hey
what i'd like to talk to you about
but but go to but i'm actually somebody
yes
if the kid is what should here's the
question yeah let me know more by the
way these aren't just teachers this is
your civics teacher let me be this is
hopefully a
like a guidance counselor let me be more
specific let me be more specific so if
the 14 year old adam is concerned about
14 not
yes well 14 i was in i was in high
school at 14. ninth grade high school
fourteen i was a fourteen-year-old in
high school i'm telling you i'm telling
you i graduated 17 years old in high
school not because of a great
bodybuilding well you were also breast
fed two or eight that's the point so but
go to 16 years old stay at 16 years yes
let's say 16 years old you're 11th grade
you're driving a car i get you you go to
your guidance counselor and you say
listen my name is adam i'm kind of
confused right now what are you i was
never confused the clearly
but you go to your guidance counselor
and you say you're confused i'm having
problems with my girlfriend what should
no no no no no this is not problems with
your girlfriend this is the the we're
talking him and her and pronouns
we're specifically on this topic here
how should the guidance counsel handle
that i'm afraid of talking to my dad
because he's going to lose it he's a
traditional jewish man or you know he's
a traditional
hispanic whatever you know so i come
from a christian family how should what
should the guidance counselor do i'm not
going to pretend that i know the answer
of what the guidance counselor should
say or not say here's what i will say
yeah i'm okay with them having a
conversation like the fact that they're
conversing and talking and they're
saying i've got questions like that's
the guidance counselor's job to have
guidance i don't disagree i don't think
i disagree all i'm asking is what should
the approach be from their end because
that's the training that's got to come
from this as a parent do you want them
to just go right back to the parent hey
by the way little timmy had questions
about whether he's gay or not do you
think he should make you aware would you
want to know that as a parent or no if
i'm a parent of course i would want to
know but maybe one minute doesn't want
to share that but i call you as a
guidance counselor and i say hey adam i
got a question for you can i share
something with your son i think you need
to know about but he it's very important
for you and i to build a relationship
together because if you go and
automatically tell him what i told you i
think you're gonna lose i'm gonna lose
trust and i'm not he's not gonna have a
person to go to can i trust that we can
build this relationship together you and
i yes i think you ought to have a
conversation with your son because he's
struggling without that dot do you think
that conversation should be at or do you
think the secret should be between the
guidance counselor and the kid that's a
very valid question i mean it's like
where where do you draw the line what
what would you want me to do forget
forget what the valid question is you
want to have kids one day what what
would you want no no no no if no hear me
i don't care what the kid says okay say
the kid says don't tell my i don't give
a [ __ ] if the kid says don't tell my
parents
if the kid your kid comes and tells me
the guidance counselor don't tell my
parents okay
how do you want me do you as a parent
still want to know or you don't want to
know
obviously if i'm a parent i would like
that's the point i would like to know
okay but if the kid specifically says
like for instance i had an issue with my
father growing up right he was a very
abusive guy if i went to my guide this
is a totally separate topic but but this
is actually a good point but if i said
hey look i'm having a problem in my
house my father is very aggressive very
abusive
it's a thing that i'm dealing with i'm
coming to you to talk to you through
these issues as tom says to process
these issues would you do me a favor not
tell my dad that i came to you to tell
you about this if the guidance caller
picked up the phone and called my
parents and said by the way adam just
came in and he's telling me about the
right move for him for the guys
counselor to do that but that's what
like this is what i'm saying a 16 year
old is not a 10 year old wait a minute
it's not a four-year-old
they have the ability to we're from
attractive abuse and we need and the
guidance counselor's purpose is to get
cps child protective services involved
so that we can protect the nation's
youth when you do have a parent out of
control we're talking not about that you
move the argument i don't think that's
intellectually honest adam but tom i
said this was something i was dealing
with i i didn't move the i didn't move
the goal post i said this was something
that i stick to
stick to him and her that's fine stick
to him and her if a kid goes to this
teacher 16 years old guidance counselor
saying i'm wondering what i am sexually
i don't want to bring it up to my dad
because i think he's going to lose it
can you please help me out with this
should that guidance counselor call the
data on the mom
no no
really not at 16. got it really no what
and um
what do you think so the reaction is
just so then why even have a yeah of
course that's my opinion just like it's
your opinion that's the whole point
everyone here has an opinion so whatever
you say is right what is your appearance
i actually want to do this let me do
this and then i'm going to come to you
and i'm going to hear your thoughts as
well okay so explain to me why
again is it is it
because want your kid
to have a
place where they can talk that they're
more comfortable than the parents
is that why or is it is it a place to
release rather than hanging on to
themselves okay let's start with the
reason that you're going to the guidance
counselor it's because they probably
don't feel comfortable bringing it up to
their parents okay let's just start with
that sure like okay i have an issue hmm
i can talk to my friends about it but i
don't want to be judged i could talk to
my parents about it but i'm certainly
gonna get judged for whatever i'm gonna
have to say it's not exactly the most
comfortable conversation with your mom
and dad about sex
okay i don't care how good you are at
processing issues i'm not trying to talk
to my mom and dad about bodily sex stuff
facts
so if this is a person who is a
qualified
professional and this is their freaking
job yeah i'd feel okay closing the door
and saying hey can i talk to you about
such and such and such if god forbid
my kid for example if they i don't have
a kid but in the future
if that led to a mental health problem
down the line because they were
struggling with this and they either
wanted to take their life or had or
struggling with something greater that
guidance counselor should be telling the
parents because it can turn into a
broader mental health conversation that
doesn't
that it's the parents job to be involved
with their child
once you're 18 fine whatever
but for that particular case i also have
a big issue if these guidance counselors
are looking at things objectively and
they're actually being professionals and
and doing their training and talking to
these kids that's a different story but
if there are guidance counselors that
are pushing this as well that's a bigger
issue is that it's all a cultural
problem i think
if the guy i mean look as far let's not
villainize teachers we're not we're okay
we're not trying to teachers have the
hardest jobs your wife's a teacher
my mother was a teacher okay i was a
teacher my mom was a teacher but
teachers have a very tough job they're
overworked and underpaid they are and
let's not villainize teachers that
they're all trying to like reverse lgbt
all our kids i'm not sometimes they need
to have crucial conversations look at
the schools
that would tell you otherwise how so
go to a public school in a
democrat-leaning state and what you see
there
is is pretty concerning what the kids
are being just in democrat leading
states so republicans are perfect
from illinois so i don't live i don't go
to schools here in florida but in
illinois if you go to those schools and
you talk to kids and what they say that
their teachers are doing is it very
concerning
if every teacher is the teacher
what the teachers are doing is very
concerning that's what she's saying but
continue if
guidance counsel i all i said was if the
guidance counselor is able to look at
these things objectively that's a
different story if teachers are able to
look at these problems objectively
instead of pushing their own political
ideologies that is different but what
the the culture is showing us is that
they are pushing their ideology and that
is a problem i love teachers the
teachers that want to teach are great
and they should be um they should be
elevated but the others particularly the
millennials are not doing that half the
time that's the problem do you have any
other angle from what we talked about
here with adam you you're you're the
only one in the room here that's got a
16 year old daughter
well
he just told me i had an opinion before
he heard what i was going to say because
it's back with facts
so it's not my opinion i'm just going
back on on facts there's a simple simple
fact it is a fact in these democrat
leaning and hard blue districts
the guidance counselors and the teachers
are actually denigrating the position of
the parent you should come talk to us we
see people like you every day i see 50
students your parent sees one you we
know what's going on we know what's
going on you should come talk to us so
that's what's happening it's not
what you just said oh i can't talk to my
dad my friends are a little confused
i'll go talk to my guidance counselor
there may be a threat of that adam but
they are being absolutely encouraged to
come talk to the guidance counselors and
the teachers that are presenting them
this other viewpoint and i'll
tell you this we need to go dig up tyler
go dig up the stats on teenage suicide
and it and
sexual orientation confusion kids are
writing these suicide notes out
talking about confusion talking about
they don't know talking about these
things and and so you want the guidance
counselor to talk to your kid
and then
your kid commits suicide and you never
knew
and you never knew well the discussion
fair point so there should be until
they're
you're responsible for them until
they're 18. they break a window down the
street technically you got to pay for
the window you're responsible for them
until they're 18. what a point what did
you hear what a power that was a very
good point because
anything they screw up with is on me so
i may as well know about what they're up
to because if they do screw up it's me
being liable for it that's a very good
point by the way two people just gave
super chats uh fifty dollars above
azul said adam these thoughts increase
risk of suicide significantly while
parents are responsible we need to know
especially
if there's another adult involved and
potentially influencing then tico
gave 199 adam is clearly adam is clearly
wants those communities to grow even
more but if
it if medium movies and social media is
killing the next generation making
people stay in comfort zone lazy and
easily upset emotionally but here's what
i'll say zoell is right yeah is that all
yeah here's what i was saying when it
comes down to this if there is an area
that's extremely think about think about
areas that you everybody is sensitive in
certain things everybody the other day
we were doing a conference call and one
of the leaders asked me a question and
then she asked how do you deal with
sensitive people okay i said what do you
mean well how do you deal with people
that are sensitive i said everybody's
sensitive
you're sensitive i'm sensitive
don't get it twisted that just because
you are not sensitive in an area that
i'm sensitive in as if you are not
sensitive in any area you have certain
sensitivities but it's going to be
different than tyler's title is going to
be different than times tom's going to
be different than a catalinas the point
when it comes down to kids that is a
very
very very sensitive area because
anything you pay the biggest price for
anything you build a business you busted
your ass for 10 years working 80 hours a
week let me let me
break it down for you that person that
runs that business extremely sensitive
about protecting the business right kids
you spend all those hours that's a lot
of sensitivity by the way the comment
about teachers being underpaid i
disagree partially
teachers get a nice little summer off
they can do some summer school and stuff
that they volunteer to do great
i think 30 of them should be fired to be
honest with you shouldn't be shouldn't
be teachers they should go to a
different occupation there's a lot of
people that are teachers that are
miserable that are bitter that are not
happy there's no such thing as a
performance basis just stick around and
you're going to get a raise every year
for 10 years that you have in place i
don't agree with that i think there's
got to be certain protected by the union
yeah and by the way even even in the
military even in the military guess what
there were guys in the army that were
there for 20 years that were still e6's
meaning
if you don't do certain correspondence
and improve you ain't getting promoted
to e7 or e8 or e9 or whatever it is to
use that same thing for teachers and
give them certain criterias to be able
to become better teachers so i think 30
percent in the military they used to do
the following when they had bad
sergeants in the army where they were
just not good leaders you know what the
army would do they'd come up to you if
you're less than 15 years they didn't
want you to retire with 20 years because
they didn't want to pay you for the rest
of your life they'd come and they would
say hey man we'll give you thirty
thousand dollars for you to leave today
flat out they'd come and say we'll give
you twenty and you know how many people
would take it a lot of them because
army's sitting there saying we're
wasting our time with this person that's
not going to be a leader here's 15 grand
leave here's 30 grand leave i think many
of these districts need to go to the bad
teachers and say here's 30 000 leave you
don't need to do this anymore so this
concept about everybody being afraid to
have to say all these teachers are
perfect stop it not all business people
are great the ones who are not great
should be fired and go out of business
not all these too big to fail companies
need to stick around because some of
them don't know how to handle it they
keep doing buybacks and using taxpayers
dollars to save their own assets for
making stupid mistakes let them go out
of business let another company that's a
better operator buy them same with cops
same with firefighters same with pastors
same with teachers anybody at the bottom
30 of what they're doing that's not good
at you ought to get fired go figure out
something you want to do and take care
of the customer so no i don't think all
teachers are the best teachers out there
doing a great job i think 30 percent of
them should get fired anyways people
maybe give one point to that i think
they're sorry just they're going but
there are genuinely there are good
teachers that love what they do they
love their they should get a raise but
they should and and but they are rare to
to find so i totally hear you i think
those teachers should be turned
here's what i would do if i ran a state
okay if i ran a state okay
say one day we campaigned you become a
governor i'm your campaign manager and
i'm sitting on the back you know we're
working together right okay you know
what we would strategize with here's
what we would do
we would take
the top 20 best teachers
we'd bring them in and guess what we're
doing to them turn them into freaking
rock stars tell me why this person is a
great teacher we'd create a florida
district youtube channel and we would
turn these teachers into heroes and put
advertisements behind them and then the
state gives that teacher a fifty
thousand dollar tax whatever bonus that
they're getting you do to 20 teachers
what's 20 teachers on 50 000 nothing
it's a million bucks but that million
bucks is going to get the other teachers
to say [ __ ] maybe i got to become a
better teacher but because we're not
doing the hero making machine of the
right teachers nobody knows what the
hell is a good teacher all we know is
stick around bro you're going to get
your 10-year [ __ ] raise and nobody
cares if you're good or bad don't do
that just makes you okay here and we're
gonna be all right i don't agree with
that i think i think the hero making
machine needs to change but the
sensitivities of parents with kids
is a real issue and this is an area
where i would feel very uncomfortable if
you're
if your kid came and talked to me
and said something to me
and said hey uncle patrick man i'm going
to talk about something i don't feel
like i can talk my dad about it he's 16.
you know who's the first phone call i'm
making
you're calling the parent i'm calling
you bro i'm just adam can i talk to you
hey i want to tell you something bro
just remember him and i got a very good
relationship and i i look at your son
like my own son man someone tell you
this but can you handle can you promise
me that we're going to keep because i
want to help as much as i can yeah he's
struggling with this and i think you
need to know this because last thing i
want to do and by the way if i don't
tell you and god forbid something
happens to your son for the rest of my
life i will feel guilty about not having
told you that because no one cares more
about that kid than the parent nobody
not the teacher not the friend not the
uncle not anybody no one cares more
about that kid
than the parents so i feel that part
that tom brought up this i don't know i
don't even know how the hell we went
into this conversation because we have a
whole lot of the topic to get into this
was not even on our list of topics today
so now we only have an hour and 16
minutes left for the real topics what he
got up here washington state now appears
to allow minors to undergo life-changing
gender reassignment surgery without
parental consent
under health insurance must cover a
gender affirming care um including
surgical treatments that were previously
denied coverage this is january 12 20.
this is the logical next step though
when you cut out the parent well hang on
how far are they willing this is the
logical next step when the guidance
counselor doesn't talk to the parent and
the child changes their mind and decides
that they are now she her pronouns from
he him so they've got this in their mind
what's the logical next step to fulfill
the she-her pronoun right so what do
they do they go see their doctor and and
on your point you said that the guidance
counselor is a trained expert well so
are these doctors these doctors are
trained experts there's only one area we
have an issue with though here tyler
i don't disagree with them i just have
one issue guess what the issue is
there's only one issue we are debating
here telling the parent telling the
parent well i know i don't know this is
the only issue so meaning he's right
that conversation is gonna be had
they're gonna have that like if i want
to join the military i'll go to ms
sinclair and i was in the sinclair i
want to join the army but i don't think
my mom's going to support it what do you
think
do you understand like okay
my mom should probably know that no i
and i agree i'm just saying this is
you're now cutting out the parent
totally so again i i don't disagree at
all that sure they'll have the the
conversation with the guidance counselor
but first of all the guidance counselor
isn't a therapist they're not a a
non-partisan neutral actor they're gonna
have they're gonna guide the child and
if they don't tell the parent you're now
having laws where the doctors no longer
have to tell their parents i'll give you
guys the final thoughts i'll give the
two of you guys each final thoughts and
then we'll move on to topic if you have
one i have one thing to say go ahead
just so i don't want to be
we're i don't want to the issue is being
conflated and i just want to be very
clear here sure there needs to be
certain trigger points okay hey i'm
having a conversation i don't know if
i'm gay i don't know i don't know i
don't know if i like this girl
totally normal conversation if i think
i'm a boy and i think about becoming a
girl if i'm thinking about committing
suicide
[ __ ] yeah inform the parents there's
trigger points that is something
completely different from hey i'm having
a normal issue those are two totally
separate things what percentage of kids
are considering changing their sex or
committing suicide the one percent well
that person those need to be wait but
that percentage is increasing
then yes in those cases inform the
parents if it's a casual conversation in
that regard and they don't want to
inform the parents i'm okay with that i
want to be super clear on that quick
point you made a really great point
about results driven in teachers my mom
was a guidance counselor kindergarten
teacher and all whatever became a
guidance counselor
she would have 30 kids lined up at her
door just waiting to see her because
they loved her so much yet the other
teachers and the other guidance
counselors barely had the same kids they
were working all the same hours my mom
would work late because she wanted to to
talk with each student individually but
yet because of the school system and
because it's not run like a business
they were still paid the same she
deserves a raise their performance
performance didn't matter and and you
bring up a really good point there and i
think that's something that actually
governors should consider 20 20 great
teachers every quarter give them fifty
thousand dollar bonus every quarter
that's four million dollars a year i
would do it if i was a governor
20 teachers every quarter need to get a
50 000
bonus given to them a state can afford
to do that go ahead tom
yeah so i want to end with facts on the
suicide side and
this is horrifying uh the trevor project
that works with johns hopkins to conduct
research studies
lgbtq youth are four times as lucky to
commit suicide than their peers
1.8 million of them communicate their
desire to commit suicide each year there
is one suicide attempt from age 13 to 18
lgbtq youth every 45 seconds
and 45 of the lgbtq
publicly identified youth have seriously
considered suicide in the past year
i mean you call it stigmas you call it
bullying there's a lot of bad things
that happen there
but you're talking about a mental health
crisis that we need a team working on
and we need parents working on it and we
need guidance counselors not being
isolated for political reasons and we
need teachers not being isolated for
political reasons because we have a
crisis with our youth and bill maher is
correct that the percentages are
increasing this is horrifying stats and
by the way to transition away from this
into the next one i don't think we could
have done a better job by whether it's
pure luck or intentional going into
salvador ramos what happened in uvalde
with san antonio this is exactly the
direction where it goes if there's
communication there's many things so
listen a lot of people have commented
about the tragic event that took place
in san antonio
over uh last uh
what 72 hours or four days ago when this
event took place this was a two days ago
right when this event took place yes
tuesday so 19 children died two teachers
died salvador ramos i yesterday and
today i've been trying to find out about
this guy steve kerr has commented on it
matthew mcconaughey better o'rourke
president obama there's pretty much so
many people we're going to go through
all of that and i want to get your
commentary everybody that's listening to
this
um so here's what i wanted to find out
about the the the shooter so here's what
we know about salvatore ramos 18 years
old
he killed 19 children two teachers okay
they interviewed the grandfather he said
he would stay in the room by himself all
the time he didn't talk very much he
played video games he didn't live with
his mother's because they had problems
uh he didn't have a driver's license he
never spoke about guns
on social media he gave hints he said
wait till tomorrow kids be scared with
photos of assault rifles and magazines
he texted a girl the morning of the
shooting four hours before the event at
7 33 am
he texted a girl saying hey you're going
to repost my gun pick she asked
what your guns got to do with me he said
i have a little secret to tell you okay
so this already happened four hours
before
uh governor abbott shared three
disturbing posts
he said uh i'm gonna shoot my
grandmother
then momentarily later he posted i shot
my grandmother who's 66 years old that
worked for the school district
then i'm going to shoot an elementary
school he shared these three posts this
is not like it's in his mind he posted
these three things right
he turned 18 on may 16th
on may 17 he bought an ar-15 rifle style
gun a style rifle and then on the 20th
he bought another one from oasis outback
he bought 375 rounds of 5.56 ammunition
he shot one of the girls students who
tried to call 9-1-1 he noticed he's
calling 9-1-1 he shot her
no criminal or mental history they're
right now doing some due diligence to
see if he's got anything with juvie but
apparently it's saying it's got nothing
friends said he was a loner he was
bullied in school for speech impediment
he came from a family of drug addiction
several months before the massacre he
came to live with his grandmother he
slept on a mattress on the floor
favorite game was call of duty his
friend said he had scars on his face
they asked him what happened to your
faces i did it myself the day before the
shooting he had an argument over failing
to graduate with his grandmother and he
shot her in the face okay
ramos fled
the home with grandparents pickup trucks
which they found it on the side
and then you know a couple people saw
him one guy saw him saying hey is
something wrong with you i'm trying to
help you and he saw the gun and then he
went out apparently one of the doors was
open in the school to get in and he goes
into the first classroom and you know 19
students he kills and two teachers and
then i brought a bunch of different
things here on what some people have
given solutions this is what i want to
do one i want to get your take
then i want to see what you think the
challenge is because there's a few
different things here that we got to
look at one is the shooter we gotta look
at the profile the shooter now we know
enough about the shooter to know what he
is obviously we're going to learn more
as times come by
is it the gun maker's fault because you
know they're going to get a lawsuit
because we heard what happened with the
lawsuit with remington had to pay 72
million right and they just said yes
they just settled and said 72 million or
what sandy hook yep and you better
believe this is coming
guys know they're going to pay for this
right
is it the shooter is it the gun maker is
it the state is it federal level is it
lobbyist is it media is it coveted
lockdown is it fauci is it the president
is it the parents is it big formal who
is it
and then what kind of solutions can we
come up with because there's different
kinds of solutions we'll talk
everybody's solutions on what they're uh
suggesting but i want to hear from you
guys so from the story you heard
obviously initial reaction tragic event
but what are your thoughts caroline i'll
go to you first number one uh evil will
commit evil and they will get their
hands on whatever they want to commit
evil with period this was a deranged
person
and it's sick to me that
politicians talking heads the media
inflame the conversation and the first
thing they try to do is push gun control
and start to villainize or vilify
the ar-15 and the gun and they talk
about the object used
more than the actual case and the person
and and the the issue behind it all it
it the focus is on the weapon when when
somebody kills somebody with a car with
a dui or whatever they don't talk about
the make and model of the vehicle they
talk
the person is is the person in question
and why they did it and
et cetera et cetera
it is so sick to me that they
immediately try to
gun control we need to ban ar-15s and
and then everybody from a cultural
perspective blue check marks celebrities
politicians
inflame the narrative
millennials unfortunately don't even
understand what an ar-15 is half the
time don't even understand guns and then
they just start creating this massive
narrative that is false tom
um it's a very good point there by the
way in regards to if the car were to we
don't go and say what's the make and
model we talk about the driver another
forward not the other way around yeah
exactly i want to make one quick point
it is awful what happened and every gun
owner believes we have hearts and it's
devastating but
it's not the gun it is the person
amen it is the person and we it's kind
of to our previous discussion how it
rolls into this i find it really
interesting that nobody wants to talk
about red flag laws nobody wants to talk
about the things that would enable
citizens to notify and give tip lines
when something's going on
isn't it interesting that the same week
this happens
our treasury department uncovers a very
subtle but deep attempt by a gentleman
in ohio to assassinate ex-president bush
now how did that happen pat
because they have early warning systems
they have feelers they're listening they
have stuff out there and they say we
better go talk to this guy we better go
figure out what this guy is doing and
they thwart the assassination if the
same type of systems and attempts were
out there in the form of red flag laws
and other things we would be finding
people that really need help and how
many things would we stop in terms of
individual suicides very interesting
that a state senator in new york said
listen the number one
problem we have with guns in state of
new york is suicides and it's not a
high-capacity magazine it's one
i said you know
the the issue is we're not getting to
people that desperately need help and so
i lean toward
you know you have to harden the target
and it looks like the door was unlocked
back by the teacher's parking lot you
got to harden your targets
anything about security whether you're
talking internet security or building
security you got to harden the target
and then the other side of it
we need the ability to
through red flag and by the way florida
has one florida has red flag laws you
can call in the equivalent of child
protection services will go out speak to
somebody
and and you know how many lives do they
save including that person because the
first life is usually the suicide
adam
i mean there's so many reasons this
keeps happening and
first and foremost
we have to protect the kids
okay because it's very clear these
freaking losers in congress no offense
you're not there yet can't figure it out
they just can't
the public sentiment is and i think
where people where i don't know if it's
the left or the anti-nra
they started saying uh gun control it
should be more gun safety or gun
education
but
the pr i think it was uh david harris
that you quoted yesterday
you probably have that oh put it up so
we can show it i mean i totally agree
with that we defend our president with
guns we defend our congress men and
women with guns we defend our governors
with guns celebrities with guns sporting
events jewelry stores banks office
buildings
factories courts all with guns but we
defend our children with a sign that
reads this is a gun-free zone
i don't understand that i am sick and
tired
of seeing this
and
i feel like when parkland happened yeah
here in our backyard yeah disgusted i
have friends
i have family members that live in coral
springs parkland when san diego could
happen under
the obama presidency when what 2010-ish
like that that's heartbreaking
and you have these you know i remember a
time where you would go to school and
you would play duck duck goose and
that's all you had to worry about and
now they're literally sitting ducks
so for some psychopath to come in
and just shoot up the place because he
knows
he's not going to get met with a gun
how deranged and how just
what a
for an 18 year old kid to say i'm just
gonna go shoot some 10 year olds
like
he knows that he's not gonna face a
challenge this kid's scared this kid's
got issues this kid's got mental illness
that's a whole nother thing we need to
talk about here there's so many
different
factors and and different ways that we
can assess this but we need to start
with the problem that these kids are
sitting ducks in school
and i want to know why though i want to
know why this keeps happening and
what the solution is because everyone's
pitching a different solution i i want
to know what the solution is you raise
your hand you wanted to say something
number one absolutely you know most
members especially the ones who are
constantly met with death threats and
whatever have armed security right i
mean that that post is very valid why
aren't we protecting our kids with the
same level why aren't we spending the
money the taxpayer money are being spent
on on ridiculous items but not on
protecting our most vulnerable on the on
the point on the on members of congress
everything has become so politicized
right now and it's incredible it's a
form it's a way to divide
because when you have politicians that
are so quick to pass legislation and to
get together especially when they have a
majority when the left has a majority in
congress they're ready to push
legislation immediately
based on what agenda they want so if
they don't like guns because a they
don't understand them b they just don't
like them they don't respect our second
amendment and why it was written as
written
they will pass what they want and they
are able to put their own influence
their agenda and use a tragedy to
politicize it that is sick to me your
member of congress should listen if you
want to come up with solutions members
of congress are not these brilliant uh
philosophers that's very true
you need to
you need to listen and find solutions
talk to people talk figure out why these
problems solve
instead of putting your own political
agenda and then passing legislation
based on your own politics well rahm
emanuel once said you never want a
serious crisis to go to waste
and what i mean by that is an
opportunity to do things that you think
you could not do before so
they're definitely capitalizing off
what's going on here here's you know
what's going to happen what's going to
say this yeah just how like we we
brought up um
the lgbt and everything that happened
with crt
so the
the the group of people that is moving
the country these days are the soccer
moms and the coveted moms we saw what
happened in virginia with uh who's the
the governor of virginia gene younkin
how he defeated terry mcauliffe in
virginia and it was all on the premise
of crt
okay and the republicans the right
they're winning the culture wars because
keep your hands off my kids you want a
sure way to lose yeah like as far as i'm
concerned there's going to be a red wave
just like when aoc came in to congress
in 2018 there was a blue wave a lot of
it was anti-trump what have you
right now i think you know you might be
a part of it and i wish you the best of
luck in 2022 midterms i assume there's
going to be a red wave you know how
there won't be a red wave is when soccer
moms or coveted moms or the moms say
yeah i just want my kids to be safe at
school and if you have the left
basically saying what the hell's going
on the guns the guns the guns defund the
police okay but that's a that's an issue
from three years ago at this point but
and you have the i'm just letting you
know what the left is going to do mark
my words
this weekend is an nra conference
in texas nonetheless so when you see all
these republicans show up at the nra
giving speeches about whatever they're
going to talk about the nra the left is
going to capitalize that and say see
these people don't care about your kids
they care about guns more they care
about the second amendment more than
anything else and
this isn't even my opinion this is going
to happen you're 100 right which is why
it's so important that you have good
messengers on our side that are able to
communicate to the soccer moms the
realities of of these things
to promote
gun safety to not vilify guns and gun
culture and when you look at the defund
the police movement i know it was you
know three years ago but that really did
impact moms because it was affecting
these local communities when when they
when the left wants to defund the police
and they vilify the law enforcement they
lost they villain they vilify the
weapons that they use
mama bears want to protect their cubs
and i will tell you we have more moms
getting their void cards concealed carry
uh talking about school choice because
they are so fed up with the way that
their local governments are running
their kids their communities and the
schools
they're more fed up with dead kids yeah
but but i'm going to tell you this here
so i could care less about the
convention that they're having and i
could care less about all this other
because that's politics set that aside i
want solutions okay so i'm thinking
long-term solutions anytime you build a
business and we're going through a
crisis and you may lose people today and
by the way this is business i'm not
talking live so don't confuse losing
people with you i'm talking long-term
solution because i don't want this thing
to happen again i was watching videos of
one of the fathers holding the
daughter's picture like this on cnn
crying emotional talking about the fact
how sweet her daughter was and how she
had a three they have a three-year-old
son and a three-year-old son they had to
explain to him the fact that your your
sister is now with god and the kid
didn't understand it because he just
wants to play with his older sister
that's 10 years old that's pain those 19
parents no matter what we do today
they're in pain the two teachers that
you lost their lives those families are
going to be mourning and this is going
to be a scar that's going to be left for
the rest of their lives however i want
solutions here's what i'm thinking let
me tell you what what's been proposed
and i'm listening to everybody's
solution um
sean whalen i just gave you the tweet
this guy has great commentary that he
posts we talk about his parenting style
what he did with his son that he didn't
want to do wrestling if you remember
that guy's story he he posted this on
instagram yesterday says he says there's
131 000 k through 12 schools in america
place an armed guard retired vet at
every school paying 75k a year that's
9.8 billion dollars to protect every
school in america right okay you look at
this yet we spend 40 billion dollars
that we sent to ukraine let that sink in
so that hurts
the left that's sitting there saying oh
we want to save we want to do this we
want to do that yet you're not using who
you already have there are 19 million
well-trained very valuable
retired veterans currently in america
men and women trusted by the government
to protect this nation i trust them to
protect our schools okay
uh the real question is where do you
stand and what will you do about it okay
so that's one point steve kerr on the
other side who is on the complete
opposite side of sean waylon said the
following he lost it in an interview
uh and he made an emotional play you can
tell he was emotional because he
personally experienced this i believe
with his father so you know you know
this is something very close to him he
says now we have children murdered at
school
uh when are we going to do something i'm
so tired of getting up here and uh
offering condolences to devastated
families that are out there i'm tired of
excuses i'm tired of moments of silence
enough there's 50 senators who refuse to
vote on hr8 which is a background check
rule that the house passed two years ago
there's a reason why they won't vote on
it to hold on to power so i ask you
mitch mcconnell i ask all of you
senators who refuse to do anything about
the violence the school shooting and the
supermarket shooting i ask you are you
going to put your own desire of power
ahead of our children our elderly and
our church-goers because that's what it
looks like so what he's saying is
his solution purely everything he said
the solution of what steve kerr said is
what
a background check okay fine so that's a
background check now let's go to another
one there's it needs to go deeper than
just but it needs to go so here's where
i go i looked up yesterday
on what percentage of teachers are cpr
certified okay
and i looked it up and i'm like okay
what percentage teachers are cpr
certified you'll see different numbers
on different states uh i have an article
here at tyler i don't know if i send you
this article or not if i don't if i
didn't i'll email it to you right now so
you can show it to everybody this shows
which
states are cpr certified and which ones
are not meaning certain states require
you to be
uh require you to be cpr certified if
you can pull that up so people can see
it the article right there states where
cpr training is mandatory for teachers
you may be asking pat where are you
going with this i'll explain to you here
in a minute alabama alaska arkansas
california colorado
d.c illinois indiana iowa maryland
michigan minnesota new york texas utah
vermont virginia west virginia required
okay
known states where bills have been
introduced none states where cpr is not
yet required for teachers is there is
arizona connecticut delaware florida
george i mean adam they're not required
right okay cool they're not required
here's what i would be asking and by the
way steve kerr was against teachers
having guns in schools okay the guy
whose name was angel vargas i want to
say that saw the shooter in the backyard
albert vargas saw the guy in the back of
the school and he went up to try to help
him then he saw the gun that came out
he's like oh [ __ ] then he went to the
car because he had a pistol he said if i
had a pistol with me right now i could
have shot him and saved these 19 kids
that's what he said albert vargas so by
the way but there's a lesson there as
well because here's the lesson the
lesson then becomes if we have kids if
we have teachers that are cpr certified
28 of them whatever it is i think that
needs to be a hundred percent of
teachers need to be cpr certified
because you just need to know how to
handle that moment we saw a video the
other day one kid that was running out
couldn't breathe somebody came and
helped him i saved his life it can
happen at any time uh
why not take some of the teachers in
school
who
volunteer to be certified
why don't we protect the teachers that
have background send them to some kind
of training i don't know make it ten
percent of teachers
make it five percent of teachers make it
something that is a group of teachers
that choose to be certified to have guns
in schools and what sean talked about i
agree with that as well so to sit around
saying oh we don't need to have any of
this stuff as a bunch of uh you
know nonsense so another one beto jumps
up and i don't know if you guys saw when
beto jumped up and tried to be
opportunistic let me tell you what you
did it's your fault it's this it's that
and that opportunity moment that's when
you know you don't let an opportunity go
to waste you know this guy's going to be
running for governor and what's his
solutions his solution a couple years
ago when he changed this solution was
would you consider confiscating weapons
and confiscating people's guns and well
i would i would definitely
consider it as an option well folks i'm
just telling you that's just not going
to happen in america it's going to be
very problematic if they try to take
guns away from people that own guns the
whole reason why people have guns is
because it is fyi
uh sammy debull said something when i
interviewed him about about guns he says
let me put it to you this way
bad guys people like me we're gonna get
our hands on guns
you want to take guns away from good
guys you have problems you don't want
guns taken away from good guys because a
bad guy like me will always illegally
find a way to get his hands on guns so
is the solution to take away guns i
don't know about that but i will tell
you for me went a little bit deeper than
is joel who was the dean of our school
um send this text to me yesterday and i
asked him i said who wrote this he says
i wrote this i said okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna read it i'm not gonna give his
full name but you guys can read what he
had to say people want to go after and
attack gun rights after this awful event
that took place i get it please tell me
though how will this change anything
drugs are illegal and we have them in
high volume in our country right now
chicago is one of the most gun
restricted states in america yet 797
homicides and
3561 shootings in 2021 and 204 that's
already in 2022 in the case of texas
school the texas church and the buffalo
grocery store even the strictest gun
laws was broken why would you think that
more laws wouldn't be broken evil would
exist you talked about that earlier more
and more the further we get away from
god
he took the angle of
faith and the role values and principles
plays
then i saw what prageru posted which was
very interesting they said since america
removed god and religion from public
life
marriage rates birth rates charitable
giving has declined crime behavior
problems in school fatherlessness has
increased look i don't know
what the solution for this is i don't
think it's one or two things i think a
lot of people are playing the role on
this i will tell you
that
if you're constantly
constantly
dividing america with media and you're
talking about who hates who
and you're agitating these young kids at
any point they don't fully have all the
information they may go out there and do
something you talked about the fact that
hey
you know uh
you know maybe they need to make guns
what not 18 and over an 18-year-old
person shouldn't be able to buy a gun
right
maybe if alcohol is 21 is the solution
to make guns 21 instead of 18 four i
mean you can go die for your country in
afghanistan at 18. for me
for me for me
what what i think
is the solution with me this is me
talking
i think the more trained people the
safer we feel
i don't want a person having a gun
that's not trained
i want more people i want more trained
people to have guns
i want people who are taking any kind of
medication that has to do with mental
health illness anybody that's taken any
kind of medication like that i don't
think those folks ought to have access
to guns until they're good these are my
opinions these are my solutions people
are pitching a lot of different ways to
solve this my only interest is
what can we do to address this moving
forward not just a let's put a band-aid
like you're saying right now oh you know
what let's emotionally make a decision
create laws and right now let's do this
no let's figure out the right long-term
solution and realize the following
as as terrible as this may sound
no matter what policies we put in place
the bad guys are not going away
no matter what policies you put in place
fatherlessness a kid race without a
father my kids are got they got very
very very strong personalities my boys
i'll come home you know how they are
i'll come home and
melva will say daddy maybe i don't
she'll call me or a general my dad even
will call me they're not listening
so when i come home it takes a second
for them to listen
i imagine if there wasn't that okay so
when they're sitting or something
there's a guy on sienna yesterday that
said if you care soma if you cared so
much about the current living children
as much as you did about the unborn we
could have saved these 19 lives and then
so conservatives say
what about the 1 million how come you
don't care about the 1 million lives
that was lost last year according to
based on abortion why do you only care
about this is this really only politics
so there's so much of political
positions both sides are taken and
they're so blinded that they're not
sitting there saying what is truly the
long-term solution instead of repeating
what i heard on tucker instead of
repeating what i heard from cooper
instead of repeating what i saw on msnbc
instead of me repeating that no actually
pause guys all that stuff you said to
take shots at me or the other person no
one cares what do you want to do about
this what's the long-term solution and
what works let's figure something out
that's where we need to go and i don't
think we're going that direction at this
point but those are some of my thoughts
about what i think is going on go ahead
yeah culture runs politics not the other
way around and that's important to note
because for example the chicago um
example is is true ar-15s were banned in
2019 in the city of chicago yet gun
homicides went up by 53 percent
regardless so it
we there is data to show that gun
control legislation and gun control
might not work
and and why are law-abiding citizens
that impacts law-abiding citizens
again the bad guys will get their hands
on on on it regardless
what happens if a kid wanted to drive a
semi or a truck or whatever into a
building like are we talking about the
the truck in the building that that is
able to still hurt
uh and kill and and on a mass scale i
mean why is the focus on the gun and the
object used and that's the issue is
again they're making policy changes
based on us on a singular narrative
instead of looking at all of these
different it's obviously a complex issue
um hunter pollock is a is a friend of
mine his sister was killed in parkland
and he
talks a lot about
one of his tweets said single point of
entry armed security
protect our schools like we protect our
airports and federal
buildings we need to fortify these areas
in our most vulnerable and we should be
that should be one area avenue of
solution that we do look at
but that's not going to happen when you
have this noise and the culture
surrounding the anti-gun movement
they are dictating right now the terms
it'll only though all they will talk
about is regulating guns and not
actually focusing on a more complex
solution
and i think it comes down to the states
and the at the local community level as
well
to have thoughtful leaders that come
together and want to make change at
their schools on a local and state level
because your members of congress and
from a federal level
there
a lot of them won't listen right now and
it's very divided tom
i agree with you
so you look at it right now and no one
is looking at the finger that was on the
trigger
go back to columbine tell me about the
age
of those guys oh
two boys 17 18.
and go to this one no one's looking at
the finger on the trigger and saying
what do we have to do to get out in
front of this
to stop the people that are perpetrating
this because the phrase is right if guns
are outlawed and the outlaws have guns
that's very true it was true during
prohibition where al capone and the
chicago gangs had
bigger and better guns than the little
pistol that the average
cop had in chicago
and so when you focus on guns you try to
control the guns
you're not going to get to the heart of
the matter both australia
and japan and you can find the stories
today did multi-point
multi-point implementations it's just
like business
i never have a single problem in
business it's not just sales right pat
it'd be sales and it's leadership and
it's their product and you have to you
have to turn a bunch of knobs
and it's not to equate business with
this situation but there's a lot of
points here that we have to look at you
know we
if we sell a car we have to fill out a
form and we have to go to dmv why
shouldn't there be some sort of you know
requirement on that but that's only
going to help the law-abiding sportsmen
who are
buying guns from each other or trading
guns from each other
you know
it's this is a multi-part problem and we
got to get to the finger that was on the
trigger and look at what was common in
these shooters because there is a crisis
in
in our america's youth there's a crisis
going on because these are who the
shooters are
and it's like what do they have in
common how can we get out in front of it
yeah
why are school zones or schools gun free
zones why is that why is that does
anyone know and why are they advertising
but anyway
that's what steve kerr
uh supported four years ago when kids
were talking about guns to make it a
gun-free zone so steve kerr's rant he
had the other day
contradicts himself
because one he wants background checks
but two he supported not having any
keeping schools as a gun-free zone well
well to be clear i'm i'm in favor of
gun-free zones for kids this guy i don't
want kids bringing guns to school
luciano just commented right now saying
every school has uh school safety
officers on site if we are really
serious as a nation about keeping our
children safe then why are they unarmed
exactly he's great
yeah but like what's the rationale there
what like hey guys listen we're going to
protect everyone the presidents the
governments the bank the congressman
sporting events the schools no guns we
can't have a gun on campus
explain that to me i truly believe it's
the culture again i think the defund the
police movement and how law enforcement
has been vilified and just surrounding
why is it that they don't
value protection and the people who
protect us it's a culture issue
i don't i don't know if it's a culture i
mean because this is it's is it this is
a question not a point but this is in
every school in america is this an
elementary middle school high school
what some schools have what's the
problem is that what i'm saying why
aren't there more
uh sean whalen who you mentioned i agree
have a couple veterans have a couple
security guards with guns
vetted secure
i don't get it i i just my brain isn't
rapping look it's become so clear
congress ain't doing anything
clearly i mean since sandy hook since
columbine has anything changed and they
talk about bump stocks you know whatever
the hell that issue was okay congress
isn't moving the needle because
basically what's happening on the right
is they're saying keep your hands off my
guns i'm not ever going to let you have
my gun it's not happening and by the way
if we've learned anything over covid the
left will overreach
and they're clearly
have the right to feel like nah i don't
trust you you're gonna come and then on
the left
they're basically saying all they care
about is their guns they care about guns
more than kids living and this is the
culture war right here right but
the the one thing that the left
and the right kind of like with the
abortion let's protect the life of the
mother the one thing the left and the
right do agree on is let's protect these
kids so let's start with the schools and
figure out a solution within the schools
and within the school systems than the
school districts because congress on a
government federal level yeah can't get
their [ __ ] so so so let me read this and
i want to i want to give you a complete
opposite comment that was just made to
get your feedback on this according to
crime prevention research no gun free
zones areas where guns are prohibited
have been the target of more than 98 of
all mass shootings this staggering
number is why such designated areas are
often referred to as soft targets
meaning unprotected and vulnerable
according to crime prevention center
research center only a little more than
one percent of mass public shootings
since 1950 have occurred in places where
places that were not considered to be
gun-free zones uh in fact a as crime
prevention research center president
john locke jr noted in october 2015 only
two mass shootings in u.s since 1950
have occurred in an area where citizens
were not
prohibited from carrying a gun very
interesting stat right there but i want
to throw a complete curveball in there
based on what tico just said comment
he just gave 20 and said u.s is the only
country where it happens so often
because no other country has that many
guns owned by the public every country
has crazy and immoral people but no
other country has such easy access to
guns
as us do you agree with them
you guys are quiet it's a pretty good
point he's making so
what do you what do you say when you
look at guns per capita i mean
the united states guns per capita is
highest in the world
can then there's this other guy mario
frady says so here's a question you
think that there would be similar
situations with mental health issues
considering this background in europe
yes of course the difference you can't
buy an ar-15 in europe
don't they have mass knife stabbings
i want the the data here
they do have mass
especially in uk yeah yeah the data
would say that incorrect mass knife
stabbings but but wait a minute versus
killing somebody is killing somebody the
weapon used is should not be the focus
yeah but that's like you know what
forget about the weapon i'm just gonna
have an old-school musket and just every
time i shoot i'm gonna reload
like that it doesn't add up if you have
an ar-15 you can go
what no you can't is that not gonna
that's not one of the rf
cause i think 40 of all shootings have
used an ar-15 specifically no their
hands that's not no true
the vast majority of mass shootings are
committed with handguns they a
congressional society by the way that's
a big number it's not a small number
it's not like
49 it's a very well why does someone
need a can you pull up what an ar-15
looks like just because it's whatever
but why does someone need a normal gun
why does someone need an ar-15 it's a
type of gun but why does someone need it
because it's a gun because it's longer
range
this is coming from a guy that owns
ar-15 and i own
a lot of stuff that i own okay and i
have it
this is my concern tyler and i want you
to push back on this and carolina and
tom
challenge this argument
why shouldn't the people that are buying
these weapons be well trained
why shouldn't there be something tied to
mental health and the medication they're
taking
why shouldn't that be okay for us to
know that what's wrong with knowing that
and what's wrong with us increasing
training when i get a car that i use i
got to get a permit and i got to get a
license right i mean that's across the
board and
a car is a weapon the car is believe me
there's some drivers in america you're
going to be driving any cars right now
right so why not focus on training and
is there anybody that's buying guns that
shouldn't have access to those guns by
the way fyi keep in mind i know that no
matter what we do
we're not going to get to zero percent
where none of this stuff is going to be
happening
but why not focus on getting people
trained more tom you build a great point
my daughter just got her driver's
license she had to certify she's not
under medication she has to take a
vision test and so it says on your uh
driver's license corrected so she's
pulled over and she doesn't have glasses
no her eyesight's fine but if she had
glasses and she's pulled over not
wearing her glasses the cop will say hey
you've got corrected vision why aren't
you wearing your glasses so they do that
and by the way
it's a very elaborate check i've seen it
with my own eyes here in florida you're
76 years old and you go to renew your
driver's license you have to go in there
and you you have to
pass a vision check so
look we require people to go to dmv
bring registration in you know you sold
your truck to me we fill it out and i
get it
okay
and we have situations where i have to
go to driver's ed and my first time i
have to take a driver's test don't i
to get my driver's license so why not
why not do so why not do this for
pat i'm with you why not do it for guns
so hang on
when you get your first weapon yeah you
have to get a gun safety course if you
want to drive a school bus you have to
get a class c driver's license to be
trained so that you're capable of
driving a bus so why not do the same
thing that your first weapon your gun
license involves training i'm with you a
hundred percent on point i think we
might be on the same page on this my
concern is who gets to a decide the
criteria on that and if it's the federal
government that's incredibly concerning
there was a boyfriend loophole in a
recent red flag legislation that was
being drafted
and what's to say just hypothetical
scenario playing devil's advocate what
if you are really pissed off at your
boyfriend and
because he cheated on you whatever it
might be and he owns a firearm he owns
an ar-15 and you go and tell the cops
that he's a deranged person and he did
all his stuff and then they go and take
the weapon away there's a very fine line
when it comes to
what government's authority is
on
on being able to decide who owns a
firearm based on our second amendment
americans
all
can
and so where where is that where does
that play i don't know i don't have to
but to make make a point here i want to
make sure that i'm not wrong in the red
flag laws they don't seize
and take the weapon away for you forever
right it's like having your car
impounded hey
we're concerned here so we're going to
impound your gun
and there's a process to go get it back
was there really a fight here were you
really upset or you're really a risk to
people and there's a process there
that's the point for the red flag now i
agree with what you say because the
people that are against
background checks for all weapons you
don't know what they're going to do
they're going to have a list of
everybody that owns every gun and then
they're slowly going to start
classifying every gun as an assault
weapon this is an assault weapon
suddenly a 12-gauge shotgun that's only
used to shoot birds is now going to be
assault weapon and uncle harry is going
to lose his bird gun if they're just
going to keep turning that knob down
because their goal is to is to get the
weapons away from you that is the
argument that comes from the other side
tyler pushback push back on what i'm
saying okay first of all i don't know
where in the country you can't
you can legally buy a weapon without a
going through a
concealed firearms course
what are you talking about in texas you
you want to talk about how long it took
excuse me there are there are 24 states
now that constitutional carry but you
still cannot buy a weapon without going
through a background check you cannot
buy a weapon if you're addicted to any
drugs you cannot buy a weapon if you
have a felony they do an extensive
background check on you and again this
isn't the problem the problem is not the
the law abiding citizen who's buying the
weapon chicago cook county has the
strictest gun laws in the country and
their shootings are skyrocketing they
have 30 40 50 people a week dying
from shootings that are being shot young
kids uh gang members et etc et cetera
and again it doesn't matter how strict
the gun laws are if you take the guns
away if somebody wants to do harm
they'll do harm right they'll create a
bomb go bomb a marathon they'll drive a
truck through a christmas parade in
wakutia wisconsin or in france 84 people
died on bastille day this was like 10
years ago in france they'll drive a
truck through the crowd
to catalina's point
people are going to want to do harm the
problem is not the gun it's the
hedonism and the lack of
of as you put it earlier the lack of god
within the country people people don't
know their lives
you're talking to a guy
you're talking to a guy that loves
america like you wouldn't believe you're
talking to a guy that was in a military
who thinks
i you know how many people i want to
have guns in america you know how many
people i want to have guns in uh
semi-automatics in america how many do
you think i want to have all of them i
want a hundred percent but 100 percent
trained
is what i want 100
trained is what i want let me read you a
couple comments that we just got here on
what i said some agree some disagree
uh uh uh so john mcguire just gave 50
bucks this is common factor amongst the
shooters lonely delusional complete lack
of purpose or belonging it's really hard
that
is it really hard to help these kids
let's stop trying to treat the symptom
and go after the cause mentor and give
these kids a purpose fine this next
person said anna bruner said i'm an nra
instructor and i totally agree with pat
on training everyone who owns a firearm
should be trained i've been teaching for
30 years i feel this is the best
solution all i'm saying is
go back and think about you know second
amendment what is second amendment it's
not a privilege right some guy commented
saying it's not a privilege owning a car
is a privilege owning a gun is
constitutional right you have the right
to have this totally get it right
but to me
even if you go back and think about back
in the days where you were worried about
somebody attacking you or even somebody
invading like government somebody comes
into your house and give me this give me
that which happens all the time in a lot
of different countries to make sure that
doesn't happen in america well how do
you fight against that
you'll fight against that against by
knowing
how to use these weapons if you don't
know how to use these weapons and you
just buy a gun to buy a gun that doesn't
mean you know what you're doing so to
train them is the solution if if if i
again go back to policies if i want my
state to be protected i want to make my
guys more trained but at the same time i
don't want somebody who is taking
certain mental health medication
to have access to weapons because
they're going through something that is
a concern that we ought to think about
that okay there is a challenge with that
some people fight back on that and i
totally understand that argument but i'm
trying to go to the point of what's
wrong with having every single person
that owns a gun be trained what's wrong
with that nothing you talk to the people
in the gun community what's the first
thing they tell you to do train gun
safety
yeah that's all they tell you to because
it doesn't matter if you own a weapon
just because you magically what if
conservatives took that position though
what if conservatives took that position
no what if conservatives said
here's what we want to do let's create
training let's make our guys better by
the way that's another opportunity for
conservatives to get a new audience
there are a lot of groups uh non-profits
that are going to inner cities like
chicago and baltimore and they're
training the communities the the the
youth of the communities on proper gun
safety which i think is a really
interesting point but i love this um
quote it was in a it was from
drivefiretrainingcards.com
guns are designed to project kinetic
force at a distance what you do with
them is a reflection of your intent not
the intent of the gun
so
we can train a million people what
you're saying with that i get what
you're saying with that and i agree
um
i don't think this is a
one point solution i think it's ten
point solution it's not only one thing
that's going to fix it all the one out
of ten that i think is being trained if
you're trained a little bit more i feel
better about it if you're not
the other part of it is you know so
here's here's something i'm reading this
book called after steve right after
steve jobs highly recommend everybody
read just book just came out it's
incredible we're talking about it before
the podcast got started
question for you guys okay so the san
bernardino shooting takes place
when the san bernardino shooting takes
place what was the biggest problem that
apple got into with san bernardino
shooting what happened would they unlock
the phone or not comey and obama went to
apple and said what unlock the damn
phone unlock the damn phone and what did
what did cook do what did tim cook say i
can't do that i can't do that
and then they try to really bully him
and he stood up and he said no
this is a bigger thing than short-term
this is a long-term issue that we got to
address right he says i can't do that
because i'm taking a privacy away from
the individual that's using my software
my phone right i'm not going to do that
they lost it they were going to sue him
all this stuff finally they said don't
worry about it we figure out if
different way to get it they didn't go
after apple right but till since then
apple's been obviously having a
challenge and then later on trump comes
out trump calls out tim cook non-stop
finally tim cook goes and spends time
with trump and next thing you know uh
people ask trump why is tim cook your
favorite president for a favorite ceo
trump's answer was what cause he's the
only one that calls me
tim cook is the only one that calls me
this is a first openly gay ceo that
communicates with trump about
you know challenges they're facing as a
company but here's a question
if
facebook knows
what this guy is texting and messaging
i'm throwing a completely different
curveball here i want to get your
thoughts
if facebook knows those dms and they
know he's communicating
should facebook report those dms to fbi
well they have no problem putting
flags on covet 19 things or censoring
people immediately and reporting
accounts
maybe they do have a role in that
what do you think tom i think they
absolutely have a role i mean if they
can shut down a conservative voice and
let's talk about what it is right you
say something too inflammatory about
vaccines or about this or about aoc
boom you know your account can even be
suspended take a bit longer but your
tweet can be popped like
immediately which means that they is
that good though is is that the right
position for them to do what they do
that's censorship but they could use the
same
technology they don't have an army of
people just watching tweets they have
technology that's reading tweets and
they can put that same technology and
send a notice to that law enforcement
agency and say hey there may be
something very bad about to happen here
but but what tim cook would say is tom
you're now giving the government enough
power to use free market companies to
abuse my privacy i got very technical
here with you on this the only reason
i'm talking about this with you guys is
because as we're going in this angle of
all these arguments of we should use
this and we should use that
the the ripple effect of how it affects
other things like you said something
earlier you said well i'm concerned if
we give the background check or or the
training or whatever they may abuse that
and what if later on somebody a
girlfriend says i think my boyfriend's
gonna do something to me and the cops go
and confiscate the weapons and all that
stuff that can lead to that right same
ripple effect when it comes down to hey
we have access to the dm reported to the
fbi so now you're sitting there saying
oh so facebook is owned by the
government facebook is no longer so
what is the right position in these you
know any anything good can be used for
bad
on the side of it but but
there's a fine line it doesn't make me
nervous it does make me nervous do you
remember the guy that we had the
facebook what was the guy that we had
facebook uh um
steve no no but what was his job he was
a moderator he was a moderator
and oh the whistleblower the
whistleblower on facebook that we
interviewed him
so i said do you ever check uh have you
ever since you have access to everyone's
dms and everyone's messages have you
ever gone and looked to see what people
have said he said i can't lie to you i
have
i said who was it my cousins because i
wanted to see if they were talking [ __ ]
about me right so this guy who's a
moderator was more concerned about it
yeah but the point is
you're dealing with the slippery slope
of what to do with this right so
you may find the current solution
because i would bet if i'm a abiding or
if i'm any of these guys and i'm in i'm
in the campaign so say the left all of a
sudden comes out and says this is why
the next person they could vilify here
is facebook and instagram and zuckerberg
that's the next villain because the
villain is you could have done something
about it because you got to blame
everybody except for the administration
right do not be surprised if today
tomorrow the next day following week if
all of a sudden somehow somebody zuck
gets caught up in this scandal
or yeah and and one issue that happens
although it's horrible but it's
doesn't it's not like this is an
everyday thing right that impacts the
privacy of
millions of americans
and these things are again it's a small
percentage of when these things happen
and
we're creating legislation surrounding
that that's impacting americans as a
whole um snapchat actually helped
a case it was an underage i think sex
trafficking case where somebody was
texting an underage person and they were
able to alert the fbi there are i think
there are some instances where that's
obviously appropriate but then again
it's that fine line of the privacy of of
people and then who's who's creating
that criteria but we're already doing
that now let's not forget that they use
geolocation geotagging the bank accounts
of all the people at january 6 and went
after all those people right they're now
labeling anybody who posts the wrong
thing on facebook against the teachers
union parents as domestic terrorists
like we're they're already using these
for the wrong reasons right like it's
perfect to work in this fairy tale world
where everybody uses things for the
right if you're already it's all the
criteria yeah but if you're already
doing that
if you're already doing that
it's kind of like when paul manafort
when i'm like listen lobbyists are the
problem in america and he says look what
are you gonna do the other guys are
doing it
so if they're already doing that for
that reason then you have to be equal
opportunity and give information for uh
uh
other side as well i would much rather
them not do it at all but if they're
going to do it for one side you got to
be equal on the other side as well so
should they be regulated
from an objective perspective i don't
think so i i honestly don't think but at
the same time
you're a fool you have to be naive to
think that
the government is not reaching out
because think about what the phone
call's going to sound like do you think
what do you think are the chances of a
person like this existing you ready
hey mark how are you
um i i'm with the fbi but i'd like to
have a private conversation with you
can you please open that envelope for me
um yeah sure you open it up do you see
what we have here with you
we have this we have this wheel i know
you're happily married and i know you're
a ceo of a very powerful company and
you're one of the most powerful people
in america but if you don't moving
forward tell us what's going on with
these things this is going to be public
do i make myself clear yeah okay so
here's what i need from you by this time
make sense moving forward when i myself
or somebody from my group contacts you i
need this information from you if you
don't help us i just assume this is
going to be public do i make myself
clear yes thank you so much for your
cooperation do you think that kind of a
conversation has already happened with
mark
zuckerberg you're saying yeah do you
think do you think a meeting like that
has happened like what jay edgar hoover
and kennedy's had back in the days like
with the mob with jayla hoover saying
just so you know this is the information
we have on you do you think that kind of
a conversation has happened
what percentage you think it is five
percent ten percent twenty percent it's
probably a twenty percent i think it's
happened remember we um we had the
opportunity to speak to
and we can say this publicly i think
andrew fastoff yeah andy fassbender he
talks about that they did exactly that
it wasn't a a marital affair but they
came in and they did strong arm with his
wife's taxes on a nothing item to get
him to move and that's the way the feds
work
yeah so if that's happening you just
have to assume that this is already
taking place and then if you are already
playing that game and your company is
already
got a as much
negative
reputation as they do to
keep telling the
administration what you know about
people that could potentially
prevent the next salvador ramos as a
salvador ramos's last name yes saba
ramos from happening anyways so what
what do you think then what do you think
about this picture remind me what do you
think about the patriot act james
snowden or ed snowden came out and said
the government i'm not with it every key
well that's that's essentially the same
case you're making i know i know i'm
saying but i'm i'm saying don't do it
from the beginning
at all no because because what you're
doing is
you know what you're doing listen
people think we're going to live in la
la land
you're not gonna live in la la land
do you know what hillary clinton just
got caught with
hillary if if this event didn't take
place this week you know what everybody
would be talking about the big law the
big lie of hillary clinton so what is
the big lie of hillary clinton hillary
clinton sitting there quietly
you know voicing her opinion about this
event yet at the same time
um
hillary clinton caught him perhaps the
most shocking lie of her career
uh washington times the head of hillary
clinton's 2016 campaign for a presidency
robbie
mook testified on friday hillary clinton
approved of an effort in the months
before 2016 election to provide the
press with research perpetrating to show
a computer link between the company of
her gop rival donald trump and a russian
bank mook on friday was specified on
behalf of michael sussman a high-powered
democratic lawyer and accuser uh uh
accused uh clinton lawyer according to
mooc he discussed it giving dubious
information to the press with hillary as
well but i believe i discussed it with
her after we kind of discussed it and
made the decision not notionally
the discussion was hey we have this and
we want to share with the reporter she
agreed to it the prosecution claimed
sussman built the clinton campaign for
this piece of dubious information and
the prosecution claims that it has been
evidence for making this claim so
these guys are doing that nonstop to the
american people worse than watergate
yeah these guys are doing that left and
right and people are sitting around
saying uh
who's getting the who's getting uh
destroyed with this or manipulated with
this the professionals are doing this
non-stop all i'm saying is behind closed
doors
you don't think one of her associates
has had conversations with social media
companies to say hey you better or else
well it's like how they always
threatened the the heads of the ceo
companies to testify in front of
congress
yeah they're always pressuring them you
have to do more you have to stop the
disinformation and i love the fact that
some of them are starting to have a
backbone
i love the fact that bezos is having a
backbone musk is having a backbone some
of them are not pushing back and saying
look
enough with blaming all of us we're sick
and tired of it bro do you realize we
created 450 000 jobs that you haven't
created we created so they don't rely on
the governor you keep bashing me here
why don't you go create 450 000 jobs
without taxpayer we're creating this
economy you're not doing it yeah so
it's a very dirty game i was uh i was uh
watching a documentary on the way here
uh of uh do you know what this guy uh
they call him the pharma bro yeah martin
shkreli you remember the pharma bro have
you seen this documentary or no it's
worth checking out by the way pro i've
not seen this yeah i will tell you in
the tweets and clips very entertaining
so what do they do so this guy's going
out there and a drug that's cost 13 he's
selling you for 7.50 and they interview
and they say how do you feel about the
fact that you have a drug that's 13
dollars and you sell them for
very strange guy right but you know what
they did you know how he went to jail
for seven years not for what he did with
the drug he went to jail for seven years
because a hedge fund used to run years
ago that had nothing to do with this and
he had multiple different companies
where he was just kind of moving the
money over from different places and
taking over money laundering motivation
what was he doing not tax evasion it's
it's multiple corporations where he was
moving the money raising one place and
moving to another company and then he
eventually got caught with that and his
lawyer couldn't win
and uh he got seven years but but the
point just got out though yeah but by
the way he'd be a great guest to have i
mean rob if you're listening to this
let's have him on as a guest that'd be a
great conversation to have with him uh
yeah he got two uh two counts of
securities fraud and one count of
conspiring to commit securities fraud so
sometimes when you get a little too loud
you get that knock musk just got that
knock
i think bezos is afraid of getting that
knock he feels a little brave today but
it's bad when people are afraid
of voicing their opinion to get that
knock
it's a it's a form of censorship and i
know they call it silencing but it's a
form of censorship and you know what's
the biggest freedom with that the fbi
rate on james o'keefe yeah so you go
into this part yeah but so you know
going back to what you're asking yeah
i'm not with it i don't i don't support
that or sweetheart hillary clinton is
the master at it but i don't support it
what was his was his name her campaign
manager a little guy with the glasses
podesta
yeah john podesta yeah remember he
blamed
facebook
for the loss
of course remember but more is coming
remember yeah he did well and by the way
he lost the election he's the campaign
manager so he's going to blame
the moon the tides and the wind and
trump
and comey
but um they directly blamed facebook and
zuckerberg because zuckerberg didn't
cooperate and he was actually trying to
to let both sides out there but there
were a lot of bots that were going on on
facebook the point was facebook
was actually trying to
and by the way they're not exactly in a
white hat here it's sort of a dark gray
hat
but they did not kowtow to it
and then
you're being blamed publicly and who was
the guy that ended up in the seat in the
hearing
mark yeah remember of course all of them
did all the ceos yeah
all the things was the one that really
got barbecued who really got barbecued
mark right zuckerberg and who got the
easy questions google
correct sundar pinchai but dorsey had to
take a lot of heat
if you go take a look at dorsey just uh
resigned from being on the board right
they just a form of almost got fired off
the board
because of defending elon and kanda on
the what do you call it the fake uh
fake bots so uh he's so that means now
dorsey and elon are united against the
board which is awesome because they
realize that whatever they do will never
be enough yeah left screen will never be
enough i got one other story i want to
read if we have the time for it what we
got 10 48.
uh ray dalio said something here tom i
kind of want to get your feedback on
this
uh first of all crypto billionaire uh
i'll skip that one i'll go to the dollar
first so rate value we're headed into a
period like the 1970s so by inflation
hedge
assets
uh farmed hedge fund uh a famed hedge
fund manager ray dalio said on tuesday
he thinks that the global economy is
headed into a period like 1970s
dominated by inflation concerns on
potential stagnation
as a result he said investors should
focus on inflation hedge assets as a way
to protect their portfolio during the
coming turbulent times for financial
markets value express skepticism about
the federal reserve's ability to tamp
down inflation without triggering a
recession he argued that too much debt
has been
created in a short period of time for
the central bank to offset without
massively increasing interest rates
uh even himself is saying these times
are coming and he's not even holding
back
how bad are things going to be tom the
next 12 to 18 months i think they're
going to get really really rough because
i think that we could be potentially
getting into a time like the full decade
where the japanese economy had to
recover because our monetary policy you
know yes it was about covet yes it was
about getting relief checks to people
but you have to remember the second
trillion that went out there was over a
10-year period correct it was flowed out
and so it basically becomes a slush fund
for congress for 10 years and so
basically that is irresponsible monetary
policy when you take a look at what was
printed you take a look at the debt he's
right what all he's saying is the
economy just ate these things
it has to digest it and there's and
it's going to be indigestion and it's
going to be inflation and they're not
going to be able to tamp it down he's
correct on an absolutely fundamental
level and what what is the alternative
right now
what is slowing down the housing market
interest rates right
so what do you do do you move the
interest rates back to zero
i think he's right you cannot do that
you can't do that no you you gotta feel
the pain so that's what i'm saying you
ate some bad beef and you gotta go
through the food poisoning and it's
gonna take time to get it through the
system sorry to use that visual i
apologize but i think we're looking at
the 10 years up to 10 years just like
the japanese economy had
if you look back 80s 90s you know he
said something that really stuck out to
me he said we're in a time where
ideologies and politics drive economics
not the other way around
and i think obviously there's it's a
complex issue with the fed and monetary
policy and decades of of things gone
awry but i also
the the political part is very important
and why we need members of congress who
are pro-growth and who understand
economics because ultimately it's the
american people are the ones who are
going to suffer when you have
politicians that want to increase
minimum wages
when you have again coveted lockdowns in
some blue states unconstitutional
lockdowns where you're destroying small
businesses all of that stuff really does
matter and it is supply chain issues all
this was incredibly political and so
when you have this kind of perfect storm
of things you need people who are able
to ring to bring it back
and ultimately again these kitchen table
issues what what americans when i'm on
the campaign trail they're worried about
going to a restaurant and things are 50
percent marked up and then the
restaurant owner all of the food all
they have to raise their prices
groceries groceries are getting more
expensive gas is getting more expensive
it has become so political and ray dalio
was so on point when he said that that
the economy is now being driven by
ideology and politics and the way it
never happened i don't disagree folks if
you want to find out like how
how and what gas prices are affecting go
go price out the flight that you usually
take
and write down the number that you pay
for the flight that you usually take
whatever flight it may be maybe la2
dallas okay maybe new york to miami
whatever it is that you usually go on
and use american airlines or
you know jetblue or some of you guys who
are extremely courageous spirit or
whatever whatever you take right
and then go price it out today and see
what the number is today go go look at
what happened today it it affects so
many different industries by the way
this article continues with another
article that has to do with this one fox
business u.s economy on the cusp of
stagflation world's largest hedge fund
warrants this is a completely different
person
uh bridgewater associate co-chief
investment officer bob prince said this
week that markets have not fully
absorbed the shock of what's happened in
the economy and investors are too
optimistic about the path for inflation
and interest rates
and stagflation is the combination of
economy
stagnation and high inflation
characterized by soaring consumer prices
as well as high unemployment the
phenomenon
ravaged the u.s economy in the 70s and
80s as a spike in oil prices rising
unemployment and high monetary policy
pushed the consumer price index as high
as 14.8 percent in 1980 forcing fed
policymaker to raise interest rates to
nearly you ready 20
and by the way
to the experts who don't think that's
possible
they are unbelievably naive because
never in the history the company have we
printed money like we have right now
expect expect interest rates to go to
that level let me give two tips i got i
want to read one other article here that
talks about
if you were the person that were too
loyal to your company you didn't go get
another raise at another job you made a
mistake that's a business insider so it
will read that but i want to give you a
tip
if you're thinking about buying a house
um
this is purely my opinion you don't have
to take it but i'm just giving it to you
if you're thinking about buying a house
and you're so excited about buying a
house
if
if you can wait 12 to 18 months do so
if you are so excited about buying a
house
that you're just like oh my god but i
love this place if you can somehow
set aside your emotional love for that
new house for 12 or 18 months you're
going to win here's why
the mortgage payment is not going to be
different you're still going to pay the
same payment you're paying today for
that house because
you buy the same house 18 months from
now that's probably a million dollar
house today you'll pay 720 for it
but interest rates are going to be eight
and a half percent so your payment's
gonna be the same
but that one million that one million
dollar house that becomes 720 it's going
to go back to them in a million dollar
house seven years from now five years
from now except you kept that 280 and
then you'll refinance when interest
rates come down five to ten years from
now and you'll pay a lower payments so
if you can emotionally
prevent yourself from jumping on the
house that you want to buy right now
wait 12 to 18 more months
it's probably going to be a wise move on
your end now people who are not going to
like me saying this are loan officers
and realtors realtors and loan officers
i love you
uh i support you on what you do
your job is to convince them that i'm
wrong i'm totally okay with that that's
how debates and arguments happen but i'm
telling you
i think i'm right okay when it comes
down to this idea with house but do you
think tom do you think it has a
likelihood of getting as crazy as it was
in the 70s and 80s of
14 type of things like do you think it
can get to a number like that i think it
has all the raw materials in here the
kindling is here that the fire could
burn that hot but i don't think it will
you know i think there's a lot more
controls and things that banks are going
to be put in place by the way don't
forget to leave out wells fargo the
largest issuer mortgages united states
that's upset with you right now but um
well let me ask you a question because
if ray dalio is right but your property
tax also goes down your property taxes
when you buy that house that's a very
meaningful part of home ownership it
could be a thousand bucks a month your
property taxes are probably now down to
650 600 yeah go but your insurance rates
are going to go up that's a big problem
that's going on here in miami is that
all the uh property uh insurance rates
are skyrocketing but here's my question
for you because that won't change though
that's not going to change no matter
what well not according to miami herald
i mean whatever we don't need to get
into the article right here but
apparently the
insurance rates have skyrocketed 30
percent because of what though
you want me to read the article what i'm
trying to say it's going to go up no
matter what though
it's not going down because of whatever
the current times are you're going to
pay that a year from now
whether you like it or not that that
that fee is not going away but go ahead
make it yeah no i mean i don't want to
uh pull out the article right now so if
if if real estate's going down stock
market's going down crypto's going down
ray dalio's basically saying so buy
inflate inflation hedge assets and i
don't know if you were using a freudian
slip right there so here's some tips for
you are you saying what should you
invest in tips treasury inflation uh
protected securities something like that
what where should people be putting
their money you gave a great speech at
the the think conference what was it
called grow live with videos grow grow
live with videos great speech it was
awesome and you said hey this is a great
time where you can add an extra zero to
your net worth over the next few years
other than making more money right you
know and choosing your uh income
producing uh
mentality better where should people be
putting their money now if if real
estate is going down stock market's
going down crypto is going down
depending where should you be so the
average person or the person that wants
to really play ball and add average
person the average person needs to
uh
if you're if you're in equities equities
is going to take a hit it's just it is
going to take a hit so but i don't want
to give that advice because too many
times when they say that
then they forget to go back in equities
when the momentum is back up and they
take a big hit for it so if you're not
somebody that's watching your stuff let
your advisor give the advice i don't
know what situation you're in uh but i
will tell you right now
if there's ever been a perfect time to
add that additional zero to your net
worth today's the time the next two to
five years a lot of things are going to
be on sale a lot of things are going to
be on sale people so you're saying stack
cash uh even though even though
inflation is at eight percent what have
you i think opportunities are gonna go
to the roof the next 12 to 18 months ask
why a buffet that knows more about money
than
99.99999 percent of the world why is he
sitting on so much cash right now maybe
because he knows how much things are
going to be on sale and he's going to
pick up things on sale it's just the
reality of it now
i do want to transition into this into
the insider story because this is what
confused a ton of people in america i
made a video about this three weeks ago
uh here it is okay look look at this
nonsense article that actually confuses
people and millions of people took
advantage of this
if you've stayed put out your company
during the great resignation you're
paying a price for your loyalty insider
may 24th over the past year the red hot
job market has forced employers to dole
out huge paychecks to lure new
candidates and that's created a deep
divide between the rookies and the
veterans at the companies across the u.s
labor iq compensation data provider
estimates that salaries for new hires
are seven percent higher on average and
a medium pay for people already employed
in similar positions for many and demand
occupants occupations across tech and
finance the disparity is in double
digits in the great resignation
long-time employees the ones who have
stuck around through good times and bad
times are paying a secret tax for their
loyalty i disagree here's why let me
tell you what's about to happen for
those who abused
that uh going to their bosses and saying
you know such and such recruiter called
me i have another opportunity to work at
this company and they're going to pay me
more money than you are and i'm going to
take the job and you bullied your
employer
when it comes time
that the market correction takes place
and silicon valley announces the freeze
that they have now on hiring
when it comes time that you see these
companies letting go of
4 000 employees
10 000 employees wait till you see the
firing and the layoffs banks are about
to announce the next three six 12 months
just just brace for impact where these
big companies that gave you that bonus
that you went to them wait till they
fire you know who that employee's gonna
call they're gonna call back that
employer that they left and say i made a
big mistake leaving i'd love to come
back you know i went and i realized i
don't want to be part and they're going
to create their own skit story i
realized i'm not a large corporation
person but this experience made me
appreciate you even more it's like when
a guy leaves a girl and goes with
another girl doesn't work out and say
she made me love you even more if it
wasn't for her my love for you wouldn't
have grown to the levels it has today
are you reading my text message i'll
just say so much
we gotta get together right now oh my
god
i'm so glad she trained you to love me
even more right whatever that may be
she takes him back yeah if exactly if
if you
were loyal during that time if you were
loyal during that time
and you did what you did
that ceo that boss of yours values you
believe me privately they're sitting
there making a list of people that they
can count on and you're on it
and this may not be a bad time to have
the following conversation here's the
conversation on how to have
hey boss
listen
uh i believe in what you're doing i
believe in the company i believe in your
leadership i just want to let you know
i'm here long term i would like to be
considered for the following i think you
value loyalty i've shown you i'm loyal
to you during good and bad times if
there is a way for me to be considered
for another position higher up let me
know what i'd like to do but i'd like to
be able to fight for a race and a
promotion i don't want to go anywhere i
love the company i want to be able to
take this company to the next level i
appreciate your style of leadership tell
me what i need to do i'd like to have
that kind of a conversation with you if
you're open to it okay my resume out
there but they somehow found me and
they're offering me twenty eight
thousand dollars more if you can give me
that raise i will because i wanna stay
with you i wanna stay with you but if
you do that i'll stay with you those
people who were that opportunistic and
adam i understand those people who are
opportunistic they're not gonna like
life the next 12 to 24 months it's going
to be hit so hard because when you go
all of a sudden be paid 120 and you're
not worth 120 you're an 82 000 year
person but your lifestyle went to 120
and now the market fires you and now you
got to go from 120 and there's not an 82
000 of your job that you're willing to
accept a 68 000 of your job a bankruptcy
is around the corner a repo is around
the corner and life's gonna get messy
and now you have to get started with a
resume that's going to show over a
five-year period you got five jobs and
that's not a good resume because
employers look at resumes to see if you
stay with companies or you go resume
shopping nobody likes somebody that's
been around the block in the job market
people don't like that tom now you get
to work from home you're unemployed from
the couch
i feel for the business owners small
business owners medium sized business
owners right now there's such a labor
shortage in a lot of different
industries and
you know there the talent is tough to
find my sister and i have our own
company and it's incredibly difficult
and they ultimately are the ones who
have to pay the price you know
i don't say that i don't think they know
yourself no but people look at things in
such a short-term way i don't mean to
throw millennials under the bus as well
but you should be paid what you're worth
but also there's a there is something to
say about experience and staying with a
company that you believe in and the
long-term growth potential there than
just shopping around and getting paid
that in a short-term way
you hit the nail on the head with the
difference between a short-term and a
long-term perspective like i just had my
15-year anniversary at
my firm my financial firm that i worked
for it's crazy 15 years and i've been
offered jobs left and right over the
last decade or so left and right
and do i entertain the conversation sure
but at the end of the day i'm very loyal
and i built in very uh good
situation in my job but i think you're
absolutely right
short-term yeah maybe an extra 20 grand
so it does sound good but when uh what's
that when the tide rolls back out you
know you're left naked whatever that is
when you're if you're skinny dipping
that's what's going to happen is
essentially what you're saying out there
yeah yeah i mean but by the way
how was your last month
uh best month i've had in 15 years yeah
they had a great month yeah yeah but but
lunch is on me guys
that's not gonna happen because the ten
dollars you still haven't paid the guys
so that's not gonna happen right servant
leaders good business people good uh
ceos good leaders do value good
employees and that loyalty so you're
that's what people need to think about
and you think about deeper things right
so people out there looking for a new
job go ahead and rewind the last few
minutes and hear what pat had to say
you're funny we are hiring though if you
are looking for a job we're aggressively
hiring right now anyways what a great
conversation we had a great conversation
lots of different topics
uh uh if if it does we're hiring okay
just so you know catalina when is your
your your give us your last uh
when's your race what's going on where
to find you all that stuff primary is in
30 days uh we are in a great spot to win
it and then november
8th is the election
uh and catalina for congress what is the
website and then catalina lauf on all
social media platforms let's put that on
uh chat and let's put that on uh uh the
description below as well folks if you
enjoyed today's podcast
give it a thumbs up and subscribe if
you'd like to see catalina come back
give us a thumbs up let us know about uh
what you loved about catalina the most
today catalina thank you so much for
coming out this was awesome yeah can
people get that shirt or is it just one
off we are we are selling them freedom
over fear we have them in black and
white uh red black red and white yeah on
the same website yeah well we're we're
putting it on there okay
but they are available sounds good so
follow up with her and you'll be able to
get that shirt as well take everybody uh
do we have a podcast tomorrow two of
them
maybe maybe two of them right definitely
uh one brian brian callum is going to be
tomorrow afternoon which is bryan
collins
bye
you